[Music]
[Applause]
Mark Sanchez Fox NFL analyst former NFL
USC quarterback uh he had the Rams and
the Seahawks this past Sunday he's got
the Niners and the Rams that'll be at 4
Eastern Sunday on Fox Mark good to see
you again how's morale
oh we're doing great man uh no
complaints over here hello to the
danettes
thank you for having me uh you did uh
give a little bit of a shout out to uh
Josh Allen on Monday night after his
fumble which uh which I did love and I'd
mentioned to the Dan Edge that I had the
ticket from the bud fumble game which
was is that the Thanksgiving day yeah
this is uh 2012. oh wow yeah you know
what's crazy is
growing up Thanksgiving
love Thanksgiving more than Christmas
before that game
I hadn't lost on Thanksgiving I don't
care whether it was like pickup football
in the street like nothing like that was
my day I felt like I had some like
special superpower that day obviously
not but it was a hell of a run I feel
like you know until you know until the
Run ends but you get unfairly blamed for
that didn't didn't the offensive lineman
get blown up right listen uh I'll never
uh turn States evidence all I know is
I've listened to the broadcast because
Collinsworth called it yeah I listened
to broadcast and it was you know what's
funny it's the same exact thing that
Josh did the other not or I shouldn't
say same exactly I don't like when
analysts do that and I almost did it
it's very similar okay because he got
the snap and he bobbled the snap because
his eyes were somewhere else he was
taking a quick peek at something and
boom he bobbles the snap and so for me I
was like trying to turn and boom the
running back's not there I'm like whoa
this place
totally fubard we gotta go so you just
turn around and get back to the line of
scrimmage and get down well that's what
Josh did he's like oh fubart let's roll
and so he runs forward and forgets they
have a cross sifter and here comes the
tight end to kick out the DN and instead
of kicking out the DN he just Nails Josh
well instead of me getting back to the
line of scrimmage um boom and we know
the rest of the story so it was um
it's unfortunate and it happens but I
mean whatever can I get this autographed
by you
oh
I don't know my connection's getting
fuzzy what did you ask if you could uh
autograph the ticket from the bud fumble
yeah right there yeah what what Seaton I
was just gonna say you know in Mark's
defense Vince Wilfork basically picks up
the offensive lineman and throws him
into Mark's face oh I know it was like I
mean it's not even clay if you watch it
from different angles it's like Vince
Wilfork absolutely manhandles this dude
that is tough I know that's why I said
that that's a tough that's a tall order
to block that guy yeah
um but yeah it was it was tough but I
don't know see like it's one of those
things you know me and the danets can
make fun of me and my boys can make fun
of but you can't Dan so I don't know if
I can do that for you oh yeah I mean
it's fair if you don't want to sign it I
don't that's okay I'll see if I can get
uh Vince you know I've gotten that
before people have the actual oh jerk
people have the
um like the picture of it like a still
photo yeah I've gone to like you know
walk out of games and stuff and we're
like winning and everything's cool and
you're slapping hands and then
somebody's like hey man when you sign
this you're just like
dude who invited this guy you know how
often would you line up behind the guard
instead of the center how often does
that happen in NFL games it's happened
it it's happened it generally happens
when you're uh correcting something or
fixing something when you uh have a
young guy or you need to give a quick
reminder and you just kind of lose your
space you know you lose your awareness
of exactly where you're at and um
you know you're saying something to
somebody you just kind of start lining
up but generally you figure it out
quickly because something looks off on
the defense right something looks like a
shade over or two shades over and you're
like wait why is this guy standing oh
why am I standing here here we go
you know uh let's look back on Monday
night with what happened with Rogers uh
and and if Turf played a role in this in
your opinion
poof
listen I know there's a argument for
grass I feel that sentiment I think it's
much better playing on grass there's a
give to Grass as opposed to Turf the
actual you know dirt can just get kind
of kicked up and you have a huge divot
uh instead of getting locked in
um I know there's a huge you know I
don't know the science behind uh all
these little black pebbles in there the
little rubber Pebbles and stuff that
people say they're horrible for you and
uh you know are they ever ingested by
players probably is that going to be
like a huge problem down the line I
don't know uh but I know it's you know
once again like any of these
major controversies it sure seems you
follow the money in Grass just cost a
lot more to maintain so
um I'm not surprised that it's the way
it is and I'm not surprised that players
want to play on grass I prefer playing
on grass my body felt better after
playing on grass I know especially for
the fast guys the receivers and DBS and
all that I mean they were you know the
low back the hammies everything it just
feels kind of weird because there's a
there's a bounce back it's like being on
a trampoline a little bit and when you
go back on you know a regular surface he
takes a second to almost readjust
so I mean what are you gonna say I don't
know you're three years younger than
Rogers have you reached out to the Jets
no and the reason is I am uh currently
on a hot streak in the booth I'm
undefeated in the booth they like that I
haven't gotten hit yeah uh you know I'm
enjoying I'm enjoying this part of my
life and you know uh career pivot I
guess would be the
um saying De Jour but uh it's
I love what I'm doing and and
to even get ready to go again like you
can go you can always go I don't care
who you are if you're if you're a ball
player you can do it but to do it at
that level for that period of time and
try and do it consistently with your
body at this point once you've been away
from it that's that's where you get in
trouble I could go play one game I could
go nail a drive right now you know I can
go play a pickup basketball game if I
want it but I'm not playing 30 games you
know you know what I'm saying I just
that's just not where I'm at right okay
I'm gonna let you be the GM of the Jets
what do you do
oh gosh
um
I'm telling you I saw plenty from Zach
and I've said this
Before You could argue both sides right
like go get a guy and then okay is it
worth
um the transition period and that person
learning The Playbook and having to
adapt to that person and Patchwork piece
work some of that thing together
or do we just you know
go all in on Zach Wilson he was our guy
he's had Aaron around him for like six
months this could be
the best thing for us and maybe this is
supposed to happen and we'll figure out
the rest later kind of deal because of
the talent we have even more than last
year I mean one of the biggest things I
saw in that broadcast the other night
was Garrett Wilson giving like the pump
up speech reminding Zach like we're good
they're going over plays on the on the
you know little iPad Surface thing and
it's like dude we're good we're gonna
get open you just hey you just get us
the ball get the ball in the air
somewhere near me I'll take care of the
rest you know you can almost get that
feeling from from the players so I think
they have enough I really do and I've
seen enough from Zach to know like if
you can just figure out a way coach
Hackett to to pull him back and kind of
protect him from himself at times
um you know you'll you'll be just fine
with the roster they have but we've seen
other players whether it's Josh Allen or
other guys like you they have rough
games where you try and do too much and
you play the hero ball thing and you put
the Superman cape on too many times and
it goes bad and the numbers end up you
know evening out and you take care of
the ball for a series of games and
people stop talking about it for a while
but
um I think they have enough I really do
think that roster is loaded to the point
where Zach can handle this thing uh it's
not ideal for the team obviously they
went all in on Rogers but but you still
have to have a backup Mark you have to
have somebody who has some experience
who doesn't threaten Zach Wilson
but then who do you bring it like if you
bring in a Philip Rivers or Matt Ryan or
somebody like that who's established
then what they're not going to play
until they're ready and Zach's gonna
play yeah kind of you you see what I
mean like you do some damage to the
starter psyche in a way
that I don't know if it's better for
well what if I brought in Joe Flacco
oh because yeah because of because of
the familiarity yes see something like
that makes sense okay that I can see
more than just like hey call Tom Brady
right now you know what I mean if you're
bringing in Brady he's he's the guy if
you're Brady if you're Brady
would you entertain
this idea
oh
uh it's just so weird because we just
did the retirement I know and he said he
was in New England Patriots
play a game in Dallas or maybe not play
and then go play a New England against
New England crazy oh my God that would
be just insane but you know selfishly if
he wants to keep playing and not come
take one of these spots at Fox I'm not
gonna argue with him I'm gonna root them
on and I'll say nice things on the
broadcast about them we're talking to
Mark Sanchez the Fox NFL analyst he's
got the Niners and the Rams after the
Rams went to Seattle that was the
biggest surprise for me at incredible I
mean I kept going what is going on here
you know wait were you saying that in
the in the broadcast I really was during
the during the timeouts and TV timeouts
and everything I would just hit the mute
button and look at Kevin cougar and I'm
like what in the hell like they're
handling them you know and and I've seen
both teams practice it's not that
it's not that they didn't have the
players in Los Angeles but you just
didn't know all of them right and you'd
never seen them and now a bunch of
rookies and young players are going to
go up to Seattle where they're they're
feeling good like the two days before
the game when I'm there in the city you
can tell kind of if you're in a city
where the team's got some juice and some
energy like there was something you
could feel in that City excited for Geno
Smith and this team to take the next
step with all their young draft picks
really starting to come of age and it
was it was a great atmosphere for
football so I just you just kind of
assume you kind of get lulled to sleep
by some of that stuff because it's in
your face everywhere and you're like
okay this is the way the game probably
should go and the Way Stafford played
the way they you know got guys like tutu
out well and pooka nakua involved and
the other thing I thought was really
interesting and Rahim Morris kind of
mentioned this to us
was um you know playing with Aaron
Donald and these young guys because
everybody asks like okay well who else
you know the last time they won the
Super Bowl it was Von Miller Leonard
Floyd and
on well when you can name three guys
like the Niners coming to town who have
Hargrave Armstead Bosa oh and by the way
Drake Jackson bailing from USC when you
can name all those guys on the d-line
you know that team's legit so I couldn't
name all these other guys I'm looking at
a bunch of rookies and they got to play
with Aaron Donald and when you play with
Aaron Donald it's like Raheem Morris
made the analogy like playing with magic
or playing with Michael Jordan or Kobe
Bryant like you gotta learn how to play
with them because that dude's going to
make some crazy plays and you got to be
ready for the no look pass you got to be
ready for the last second dish you gotta
go set the pick do all the dirty work
and every once in a while you're gonna
score 15 to 20 points but not every
night Aaron Donald's gonna score the
points he's going to get the sacks he's
going to get the accolades you got to
work with him you got to go do the dirty
work and take on two linemen and the
half back and let him run free and do
what he does so it was interesting
watching that happen and Turner Byron
young these guys that they have they can
clearly do it it was fun to watch
how sustainable is Dion's success at
Colorado this initial season
I think listen they got a lot of
momentum there's no question about that
it's about
are they going to be able to adjust not
just uh game to game but like half time
first half to second half uh are these
when when some of this stuff wears off
and somebody gets them down like they
were in a little more of a battle last
week against Nebraska early uh they were
in a battle with TCU but I want to see
them down 10 14 21 points and then at
halftime and see what this team is about
and get them through all those
situations I want to see um uh you know
they're riding so high with confidence
because they've checked a lot of those
boxes right Shadow Sanders did it in two
minute drills in crucial situations
third down Red Zone he's been handling
it so I want to see when a game starts
real slow for them and then watch them
turn on the gas before you like fully
jump on the bandwagon but I can't lie
I've been so impressed and so pleased
watching them you know I got that that
date circled in a couple weeks for my
boys to go play uh Colorado yeah I know
you got that uh coming up that'll be
interesting Oregon against Colorado but
you got Colorado Colorado State coming
up uh this weekend hey great to talk to
you again as always and have fun Niners
Rams that'll be at four Eastern Sunday
on Fox thank you Mark
appreciate it guys we'll see you Mark
Sanchez